tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo tornati
suoni e spero che video vi piaccio
preparate le coperte un bel the caldo da
far saltare in aria imbrattare tutto il
muro quando prendete gli infarti e
niente godetevi il video della ragazzi
ho capito quindi adesso prendo la roba e
salgo la scala così non devo così anche
se la porta è chiusa fotte sega e quindi
[Musica]
se morisse tutta la stirpe ma poi
scusatemi ragazzi ma perché diano e
monet fase di stupido giusto ho trovato
l'oggetto pezzo blu quindi adesso la
porta è chiusa
non si apre io posso andare solo sono
figo dunque ragazzi in realtà fa c'è un
quadro che uguale a quelli di prima però
non ha le cose colorate quindi non ho
capito se devo ammetterlo qua non devo
ammetterlo con questo quadro è finto
probabilmente non devo metterli zio ma
vero
no ma serio che palle ma vuoi essere
così tartassa maroni non visto che più
stavolta si è stancato presto è strano e
raro yes funziona però mancano altri due
pezzi quindi niente
e dove li trovo agli altri due pezzi e
che ne so io c'è qualcos'altro da fare
in sostanza non ha infatti lo sapevo i
dovuti dalle altre tende cerchio
quadrato affiliato sono i tasti da
playstation pentagono triangolo perfetto
sono 30 45 30 e 45 sarà un codice per
forza però non ho capito dove c'era un
bastone nascosto nella nella panchina è
per forza questo non vedo altra
soluzione da prendere st chiave per
l'unica spero di arrivarci poi magari
non ho trovato l'oggetto chiave dello
studio hai già preso anche perfetto
questo fa le cose in fretta chiave dello
studio ragazzi non so che di che
studiano stai parla è questo qua la
porta e chi no niente
ma no questa non l'aveva aperta accusata
la chiave dello studio india che in
studio grosso cielo che cos'è ma mi
legge che stavi lady scrivendo un porno
devo sicuramente spostare la sedia per
arrivare al quadro che lo so che serve a
qualcosa la sedia sono si sposterebbe
hai scassato un bicchiere a no è cascato
il quadro a caso è caduto da solo come e
fisicamente possibile che un gatto stia
dentro un quadro era grosso sto qua cosa
cazzo era cos'era quella roba lì
terminano capito ha preso le sembianze
degli atto non chiuse mi fate mettere la
sedia sotto il quadro ricercate non si
scassa c'è un dipinto sul muro grazie me
ne ero accorto anche prima scusa non è
scientifico un prodotto regalo e va bene
quanto corre
mica come si fa i rettilinei sto tizio o
donne fortissimo ma che vai vai vai
veloce la città celebra oggi alloggio
lecce mikami cura vincolati 41 angolosa
piccola entrato dice no mi sono salvato
non so come mi sono salvato lo so come
basta ai cagato al caso basta seguirmi
quanto vale il 9 meno sono vivo per
miracolo regga solo fatto vivo per
miracolo se non è possibile è
velocissimo sto tizio che non ci posso
credere sarà basata soprattutto è
assorbito un supereroe zio cos'è sta
roba
mi piace un po a me ci sono delle viti
nel muro va bene svitiamo il pilot di
osmi tato muro ragazzi la mia vita è
completa ha svitato muro ragazza
qualcosa sarà servito acqua e questo il
codice 3 al 3 a triangolo cerchio quindi
0 quadrato 4 e pentagono 530 voto 5 ho
trovato l'oggetto chiave della cantina
perché questa qua non è una cantina mi
spiegate cosa serve cosa o svitato non
lo sapremo mai spiegate chi è quel tizio
ma ecco cosa serviva a staccare le viti
del muro mica perché c'era il quadro
abitato ho trovato l'oggetto pezzo blu
ok perfetto mi manca solo più uno pezzo
blu manca l'ultima regata e dopo di che
si apre con la porta lì che non ho idea
di dove porti perfetto ragazzi chiave
della cantina che l'unica a porta che è
rimasta ad aprire che le questo punto le
prigioni per forza è l'unica usata la
chiave della cantina profumi salvare
prima cosa cazzo è ok
buongiorno no no non siamo nel centro
fitness no vabbè ma spiegatemi ma sapete
che il tizio che mi ha sempre seguito
alla fine era il più bello io non credo
di essere proprio un pezzo dell'orco è
però voi non è che state messi troppo
plan e già nel senso tanto c'è anche il
tipo che corre come flash in mezzo
fantastico
salve un giotto che se vicino a lei
erano chiusi si aperta porca [ __ ]
veloce madonna noi che brutta cosa
praga non erano chiusi non erano chiusi
che brutta cosa e successo dove devo
andare cosa devo fare io li indietro non
ci tornò mai più
no non mi hanno seguito ma veramente io
ho paura sinceramente ad andargli due
sono andati ma siete scemi dove sono
andata erano in troppi come hanno fatto
a sparire come non li avete visto anche
voi non sono pazzo io no va bene non è
possibile che se sta roba pezzo blu
veramente ho trovato l'oggetto pezzo blu
si vabbè ma takuro no non è vero non ha
taku lo stai bene se stai bene sto cazzo
si ci è mancato un so è veramente the
cure ditemi che si mostri parlano pure
mi metto a ridere e pericoloso andare in
giro da soli posso venire con te mi pare
un'ottima idea andiamo non lo farete
corosiniti ma verame apparentemente
davvero takuro doveri andò venieri
volatilizzato spiegami ma questo è scemo
e non ho capito dal certe cose non le
capiti sto gioco non capì come ha fatto
takuro ad essere qui mi spiegate come ma
è impossibile all ultimo prezzo e ce
l'abbiamo fatta
poi non so cosa ci sia la dietro
bastarda era takuro questo è takuro
questo [ __ ] sapevo lo sapevo che
non è il tak 1 mi stai prendendo per il
culo dall offerta sono stupita lui
curato madonna come lui curato vai vai
vai veloce velocissimo come lo il
curatissimo veramente a cui non era
takuro a ok perché non ho capito serata
cura o meno hanno perfezionato grazie
quindi parlano anche cioè fantastico
oltre a prendere le sembianze delle
persone parlano ma ci mancava veramente
solo questi grandi orzo recherà pezzo
blu ce l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi proprio
completo è aperta anche la porta
perfetto sayonara pepe non so che la
spesa fatemi salvare che non ho capito
dove porta sta roba santo iddio perché
devono esserci sempre tunnel su tunnel
uno più brutto della bastava sono fuori
sarò fuori
dove la tangenziale veloci però non ci
credo dove sono
no non è vero se non posso nascondermi
man curatissimo questo è successo ho
corso e corso fino a tornare in città ha
quindi sono scappato il nostro nomi sarà
più inseguendo e quindi non è vero non
ci credo
cos'era quella cosa blu non ne ho idea
ma takuro agli altri sono ancora
scomparsi ma se sono morti deficiente è
successo così è un altro che ha provato
entrare nella casa e non riuscite a
uscire
oh mio dio ha via via al mio dio non ci
credo è finito così c'è finale paura
regalano vabbè non ci credo bellissimo
nome è finito così liberamente non mi
ricordavo più fisi tempo impiegato 2 ore
2 ore e 3 minuti e 30 secondi e quindi
ragazzi questo era a oggi e non me lo
ricordavo per niente il finale pensavo
finisse bene perché sono morti tutti
quello è un deficiente che non ha capito
che sono morti e poi il mostro è ancora
dentro quindi in teoria potrebbe esserci
il 2 che però non ci sarà perché da 12
anni che è uscito il suo gioco quindi
ragazzi lasciato il mi piace sarà serie
vi è piaciuta a me personalmente è
piaciuta un sacco infatti me lo
ricordavo che il gioco era così bello è
stato veramente emozionante di giocarci
a distanza di anni perché non mi
ricordavo quasi più niente e niente
ragazzi spero che a video vi sia
piaciuto credo che l'episodio e cose in
seguito ad un commento è un mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook come noi
video trascrizione consigliatevi nuovo
videogame sempre rpg da fare dopo
dopo anni visto che mi sono preso bene
questi giochi qua senza restituisca il
diavolo costruito dai ragazzi